but what was remarkable about the stadium was it actually changed the way
football was played in America
because in the early nineteen hundred's it was a brutal and violent game
and President roosevelt who was actually a harvard
grad and had watched a lot of the games here
wanted to get the game safer
and
the two options were widen the field or authorize the forward pass
and at that time Harvard had just built the stadium
and you couldn't literally
go
east or west on it
so they authorised the forward pass and
the joke was that it took Harvard another forty years
to actually use it
because it only seats thirty thousand there are not
many bad seats there
so the first time I got inside was probably
nineteen sixty two
and what was amazing then for many many games was
it was either at least twenty to twenty five
thousand or
for the most part it was full
I think one of the things that
the people like about it is there's an intimacy to it
that you don't find for example at Yale
which which is
much more probably sixty eight thousand
and of course back then the Dartmouth game was always here
so
it was just a great way to spend a Saturday
John powers class of nineteen seventy